un morceau de polystyrène expansible
qu'on met en contact avec le psy même
qui est donc normalement il va passer en
solution très rapidement
il ya un petit côté magique avoir du
polystyrène un des plastiques est plus
utilisé et les moins recyclés au monde
littéralement disparaître
lorsqu on le plonge dans ce liquide ou
demeurant parfaitement naturel ce
procédé dissolution est au coeur même de
la technologie de police tivers une
jeune compagnie québécoise qui
inaugurait son usine modèle de recyclage
du polystyrène
mais quel est l'avantagé de dissoudre du
plastique avant de le recycler les
policières expansé ici ça ne pèse rien
ou c'est conçu de 98 % vers de seulement
2% polymère le transport coûte très cher
sous forme liquide on peut transporter
10 fois plus de polystyrène du lieu de
collecte à l' usine de recyclage
la technologie développée par pauliste
hiver permet ensuite de séparer le
polystyrène du sol 20 de purifier et
d'en faire des granules de polystyrène
pur à 99 % epr et être réutilisées un
exemple parfait d'économie circulaire ce
qui est circulaire parce qu'on utilise
la même chose tout le temps pour faire
la même chose on n'a pas besoin de ré
extraire du gaz ou du pétrole
on laisse les énergies fossiles dans le
sol donc c'est là qu'on a un impact
majeur sur les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre la technologie de paul estival
c'est du déjà des géants comme la
compagnie française total
oui c'est intéressant 7,1 des procédés
qui est en concurrence avec d'autres
procédés mais qui aujourd'hui est le
plus avancé et le plus intéressant pour
un producteur comme le nôtre au québec
l'entreprise veut surtout augmenter le
volume de polystyrène recyclé qui est
très faible en ce moment bientôt vous
pourrez mettre vos coudes yaourt vos
emballages d'électro dans le bac bleu
et puis ils vont aller dans l' usine qui
va faire leur recyclage ça s'en vient
très bientôt
au québec plus de 80% du polystyrène
utiliser termine ces jours au site
d'enfouissement ici normand grondin
radio canada montréal